i guess this can only go one way from
here right and that's downhill right so
uh thank you very much that's um that's
uh you know a very nice introduction so
i hope i can even get close to living up
to that um so i would say at the outset
um i try and make matters as interactive
as possible
so if i do say something that's kind of
ambiguous or you don't understand
what i've done or said
then please fire away and ask right and
if it turns out that i've got through
two slides after 40 minutes then i will
be very tough with the remaining people
who kind of uh
pop up with a question
okay
just before i start on the talk proper
which is as michael says it's about um
the notion that we're trying to
outsource a lot of our memorizing
onto digital objects i want to just talk
have a quick plug for two other areas
where i'm actually pursuing research and
the first area is online communities
which is i guess like a lot of people
are interested in that
um
one of the things that we think is
missing from this area is there's a lot
of empirical study
but what's not really been tackled is
that the majority of online communities
fail so according to our own our own
statistics something like
by some
you know moderate criterion something
like 85 percent of online communities
fail and past it there are two reasons
for that one is technical and the other
is uh social
um and what we're interested in doing is
trying to build um
i i guess kind of tools um dashboard
type tools which allow designers of
online communities
to monitor and adjust
their progress in developing a community
and in particular one of them the things
we're getting very interested in is the
whole focus of web20 has been on end
user creation of content but you know
five minutes on facebook would tell you
that what a lot of people are doing now
is they're just sharing links so it's
more about curation than creation we're
very interested in the process of how
in online communities you basically kind
of manage and re-refer to and repackage
existing content so that's the direction
we're going in right now we have a bunch
of tools and this is a collaborative
project with uh ibm
okay
and now just on the on the pim topic i
just want some breaking news
a couple of
bits of breaking news here um we've got
one kind of pretty funky nsa style
project going here which is basically
show me your file system and i'll tell
you all about yourself
right so um what we find for example is
by looking at your desktop i can tell on
classic big five personality dimensions
i can tell whether you're neurotic or
conscientious just by looking at your
desktop which is kind of interesting i i
mean i guess the backdrop is spooky
these days but we were just interested
this was something we kind of seen
empirically it was an intuition that
people had and i guess now we can kind
of basically
we can uh prove that relationship
the other thing uh direction that i'm
going in which is uh again again pretty
interesting to me is um trying to look
at the relationship between the brain
actually doing neuroscience and looking
at how we
i guess manage our personal information
and one of the paradoxes which mike will
be very familiar with is
that when we're operating with our
personal information we're very reliant
on navigation for it right that's to say
we're kind of clicking through uh an
organized file hierarchy to find stuff
and there are all sorts of imprintable
reasons why desktop search you know that
thing at the top right hand corner if
you're a mac user you know why that's a
more efficient way to do it because you
don't have to remember you know the
specific location of something you can
just remember a file attribute however
you know time after time study after
study we find that people prefer to
navigate so it's something like i guess
people search about six percent of the
time and that's that's interesting
because that's independent of the
quality of uh your search engine
so one of the things we're interested in
was was there some kind of right very
deep biological reason why people did
this and what we find is the answer is
yes
right so if if you give people stuff to
find on their personal computer if
they're searching for it then they use
the linguistic part of their brain
which is also known as broker's area
if you ask them to find something by
navigation they use basically the animal
past their brain which is exactly the
same part of the brain that they would
use if they were physically searching
for an object such as lost keys
so what our argument is you know and you
know knock me down right now is is kind
of that the preference for
this uh
uh this uh
navigational preference reflects a
deep-seated way that we actually want to
kind of on a
a very highly used way practice way of
of accessing information which is using
physical navigation even though of
course if you're looking for stuff in
your that's virtual net you're not
moving in in a real physical environment
anyway so just that that's just kind of
a placeholder because i think it's an
interesting direction that we can maybe
take um hci researchers i'm very
interested in this bridge to
neuroscience anyway anybody any
questions about either of those two
uh the second one fairly bizarre
directions
okay
so um i want to talk today about um
some work
some work i guess i've been doing this
style of work for about 10 years now and
i want to take you through
three different stages of this research
and three different approaches to the
idea of
um if you like remembering or
reminiscing using digital materials
and what i want to do first is i want to
take a very classic um
cs technology inspired approach to
memory
which is the life logging approach so
how many people here are familiar with
life logging
okay well the basic idea behind life
logging is that you try and record
everything and you know in these days of
the nsa you know we're saying that
that's not too weird to be thinking
about right
and as we move into an era of
um you know wearable computers sensors
you know maybe brain sensing then a lot
massive amounts of our personal data
will and can end up online
so the idea behind this perspective is
just that we'll just be you know we'll
be recording massive amounts of data
about ourselves and that will mean that
we basically don't forget anything right
because everything is recording in some
way
so that's the first perspective i'll
explore and i'll i'll talk about some
studies that we did to actually see you
know evaluate the truth of
with current technologies what that kind
of perspective looks like
then i want to talk about um you know i
guess a reaction against that which is
trying to look at situations where we
don't want to remember stuff right and
i'll explore a study that we did which
led to some designs which we're talking
about uh which were addressing the
problem of for example if you're in a
relationship you may not sorry if you're
in a relationship which breaks up that
might be a situation in which you don't
really want to quote to remember
everything so we talk about how people
feel about digital possessions in that
context you know the fact that every
online song reminds you of that other
person you know you've got uh your
facebook feeds full up of you know
friends of that person or references to
that person you fall across did you come
across digital photos uh of that person
these are all now part of our extended
memory and that can be kind of
destructive in a situation where you're
trying to move on so we we talk about
people's experiences some studies that
we've done looking at people's
experiences in that context and i want
to present some designs for helping us
kind of get through that stage
and the last thing i want to talk about
is some recent work i've been doing with
a system called echo
and what we're trying to do with echo is
we're trying to promote psychological
well-being
by
using digital data about our pasts
presenting it back to us having us kind
of rethink
past events past experiences and seeing
whether that can actually allow us to be
um
if you like more mindful about
recurrences of that situation uh about
situations that upset us about
situations that we like and maybe take
adaptive actions when we have that
greater knowledge right so this is you
know i mean i guess my big plug for this
last style of work is you know the nsa
has basically taken a lot of personal
data away from us what i think we can do
with this type of application is kind of
reclaim that type of data and sort of
use it to increase our own
self-knowledge and you'll see i'll
present some data about deployments of
the system and i think we've got some
really striking results which show that
basically we can make people a little
bit happier by deploying this type of
system
and i mean that in a scientific way
i don't mean that like they smile more
when they used it
okay
so um
michael alluded to this i i want to i
guess talk about um you know
different outputs that i
for this research
um so i'll talk about new technologies
uh that we devised to evaluate and
actually improve the outputs of life
logging which is the kind of remember
everything
perspective i want to talk about
evaluations of existing technologies
such as facebook so when we look to the
relationship uh issues the issues that
people had in moving on from a kind of a
past relationship one of the things that
we ended up doing was scrutinizing
facebook very very closely so that's
looking at empirically evaluating an
existing technology and then i want to
talk about some you know in as i weave
my way through this i want to talk about
different new technologies that we're
trying to invent in this context and i
want to talk about technologies for
impulse control so one of the problems
that people have in the context of
moving on from
a
sort of past relationship is they kind
of can't stop themselves reaccessing
information about that person so we i'm
going to present some designs
for technologies that can kind of help
you control yourself better
right
so the situation is how do you stop
yourself doing that thing and then i
want to talk about uh finally i want to
talk about this um
this uh what i call technology mediated
reflection which is these technologies
which allows to scrutinize and better
understand our pasts okay so i'll be
talking about those different types of
outputs as i go along
okay so the first thing i want to talk
about is life logging and i guess i gave
you the kind of t-shirt a church slogan
version of it so basically the life
logging vision says what if we could
automatically save records of every
single bit of information we ever
touched every event we experienced our
reactions those events so you know you
know like sensors that do um
you know pulse or skin conductivity
that's emotion detection
there are a bunch of uh you know
startups that are selling that type of
technology now
so we have
potentially all this information you
know one way of thinking about it is
it's like a
facebook timeline on steroids about
ourselves all this extra information so
what if we had access to all that
information wouldn't that be a good
thing because quotes we would never
forget anything
so
um i photoshopped that i'll just be
clear about that that is not a member of
the royal family behaving that way okay
so
the the idea behind this is that we have
a complete and accurate digital record
we'll never miss a thing and the notion
is that in some way our wet wear our
brains are you know they are substandard
they need to be fixed so what we're
going to do is add all this additional
data and then we solve the problem
okay so i just want to talk about um one
study and a couple of pieces of
technology in this context and so we
asked this basic question which which
which i guess now in the ear of google
glass this stuff was done about five
years ago is becoming more pertinent so
the question you can ask is
excuse me what happens if we have
amazingly rich records of our everyday
lives can we actually remember more
stuff
and if so how how do we do that kind of
thing i'm not going to talk about
ethical questions in this context i'm
happy to talk about those those
afterwards but that's not really what i
major on
okay so we did a study with senscam how
many people here are familiar with
centicam
right okay so it's it's basically it's a
product that was developed by microsoft
and it's a sensor driven camera
so you wear it here around your neck
i'll show you outputs in a minute uh
it's got a fisheye lens and um it the it
triggers it takes an image every time
there's a change in light there's a
temperature change or there's a motion
change so basically if i walked out of
that door it would sense my motion take
a bunch of images then as if i stepped
outside the light would change another
image would be taken and
what the result of this usually is if
you're wearing one for
let's say um you know normal i i guess
about 14 13 14 waking hours you've got
about 7 thousand images right depending
on your activity level you know it can
be as low as three but
you know around seven thousand
and what we did then was because this is
like prehistoric times we uh separately
this is a garmin gps but we wanted to
co-index it to um location
so we've now got images that are
basically co-indexed to location so we
know where you were when an image was uh
when a photo is taken
so um i'm just going to show you what
the outputs are like so um i'm going to
show you this and then i'll ask you
kind of what you think was going on
right but this is the output remember
it's a fisheye camera it's worn round
the neck
isn't this cool
okay so um let's see how much you know
that's a view into somebody else's life
right obviously she agreed oh gave one
away i was going to ask you the gender
but you could have all told me that
right because
how do you know that person's female the
bracelet the bracelet yeah anything else
there are she couldn't think of an
account by which that was a guy but
unlikely
yeah right um okay anything else that
you can say about that where did that
person
live
did they live here no you're on okay any
more ideas there isn't you could have
sold more precisely yet
no close
she's actually biking on the left side
of the road
so that's there's only one solution to
that particular conundrum right um yeah
so anybody want to tell me anything else
about that person
that you saw
interesting
how do you know the pure shoe i was
hanging out with oh i guess yes right
right
so they want a drink right because they
had two separate two alcoholic drinks in
that time right greek food you wouldn't
have got that that's reversed
but anyway so what you can see with this
technology is potentially
just with this kind of sensor driven
camera like something that you could
have with google glass you know you've
got these apparently amazingly very very
rich records of what's going on
so anybody any questions
about that yeah
but it seems really limited usefulness
unless you you can actually process the
information okay let's come to that hold
that thought
okay so
so our question so we basically build uh
built an interface where you could kind
of fast forward and stop through your
day
right and we
our questions our research questions in
deploying that and i'll see some other
interfaces to it are does this type of
life logging help memory how does it
help so questions we can ask are can
people remember more events from their
past can they remember more details then
we can ask a question you see
one of the things that i think a lot of
people get wrong about quotes digital
memory is that
these are kind of external indices
they are cues to help us remember these
aren't the memories themselves so said a
different way
you might have forgotten that you went
out to dinner with that person but just
seeing that image might actually remind
you about it
right so that's a cue to help you
remember it's that the digital stuff is
is a cue that will actually uh engender
or improve your memory so i'm sure
you've all had the experience of you
know looking at old photos with a friend
um or a family member and you know
you're in the photo you have no memory
of it right but you know you must have
been there because you can kind of see
yourself in the picture right so there's
this reconstructive element which these
types of technologies um bring
so the other thing we're interested in
is people's emotional reactions um
to uh seeing these types of pictures so
classically you think about social
settings uh photo sharing is a
classically social
um
exercise where people you know it
engenders positive emotions and bonds
between friends and family members
okay so we did a study where people they
wear the sense cam
they have the garmin they wore it for 18
uh they wore it for two weeks
and uh five weeks later we tested their
recall and we used the classic um
psychological oh sorry um we had four
different interfaces because we're
interested in um
various different types of of ways that
you can actually represent the
information
so this is me with wet wear so one
control condition is i get no technology
another uh condition for retrieval is
we're going to ask you a question about
what you remember it uh in a day all you
have is gps
information uh another setting is the
top one there called snaps all you have
there is just those images that i showed
you with a way to kind of fast forward
and stop through your day
and then this is a combination of those
two
which whereby you can basically click on
a location you can see the image right
so we've co-indexed those two right and
we asked the question you know how do
those different type of interfaces how
do they
promote recall
so the basic question we ask people
and we ask them
about a particular half day
and this is a typical question that's
used by psychologists to probe how much
people can remember about past incidents
so i might say to somebody what did he
do where did he go and who did he meet
on you know whatever instantiating that
monday morning december the 16th which
is a day for which they have data
uh sorry half day for which they have
data right and then when they've told
the story right so they can use the
technology if that's the condition
they're in if they're in the wet wear
condition they just have to try and
remember and then we ask once they've
done their recall we asked them a
question which is you know do you do did
you literally remember it right did you
see it in your mind's eye or is it this
situation like the one i told you about
the old photographs is it one where you
see the thing and you kind of know that
you must have been there you can kind of
infer that that's an event that you
participated in but you don't actually
literally have a memory of it so for
example that person might see themselves
in that restaurant they might see their
hands there and they might know that
they were there but they don't have
you know they don't have a the feeling
they can't see that event in their
mind's eye the last one is you know like
playing guesswork
and then we give them a simple linear
scale where we ask them to rate their
happiness
you know how they felt you know when
they saw that sequence of images uh
associated with uh that particular myth
that's that's right what you feel now
about that event
okay so
we're one of the
the the thing that we're looking at then
is the number of events where an event
could be for you guys going to class
you know driving the kids to school
going out to lunch and then so and
events can also have attributes so we're
scoring
the raw number of events and also um you
know these attribute properties of them
okay so in this setting whatever
technology your condition you're in you
know it could be one of those four yet
as long as you like to look at your life
log or other you know if it's gps to
look at that log
um and the question we ask ourselves is
compared with wet wear how many extra
events do you think you'll be able to
recall so this is a group exercise for
all of us you know so just think you
know if if the total recall if life
logging if that intuition is correct
you know you would think it would be
kind of about this order right
you think about your calendar yeah terry
yeah don't think about how it responded
what do you say what do you coach the
mom to be an event so i can say i got up
in the morning put my feet on the floor
i took three steps i walked toward the
bathroom i walked into the bathroom i
opened the toilet i mean i could give
you 50 events before i got out of the
bathroom
if i defined event that way
so we kind of coached them to be
the whoops okay the game guy
sorry um
so
whoops
so we give them these types of examples
so it has to be kind of extended it
can't be at this this kind of micro
level it has to be something that's
extended over a minute so we give them
examples of this right and this is what
they do in the psychological studies
when they're testing autobiographical
memory but i guess looking at my watch
is not
an example of an event but going to a
meeting might be having a coffee
um
you know
um i don't know going out for a meal
these are all uh kind of event types
they're extended over time they're the
kind of things as i say that you might
calendar
right
i should say that people didn't have a
it's in people that i i understand
logically and philosophically have we
got any phil i mean of course
philosophers are going to kill us for
talking this way but
in ordinary language people respond in
in kind of the right way
okay so
this to us was so this if you remember
it's asked about a half day so we were
kind of pretty surprised at this
right so what we're saying is you get
like about 3.5 extra events boost per
day through using this type of
technology right so you can remember
three extra things that you did
and what's kind of very interesting to
us
down here is that that's not
statistically
significantly different so just looking
at a bunch of images is no better than
you know
just
you know trying to remember
you know trying to remember it out of
your own head and i should say we're not
alone in doing this uh abby selland's
group also got very very similar results
when they ran a very similar study so
what's going on
why is this so bad why why don't we get
total record i did
can you say a little bit more about how
they use the technology so how they
would do retrieval in that case yeah so
so basically we'd ask so let's say
you've got the full you know full uh
ball of wax right so you've got time
stam sorry you've got the gps and you've
got the images so i might ask you that
question and then what people would
typically do is they kind of fast
forward through as we just did there you
know and they'd say oh okay i guess that
was the day when i left work early
right and i decided i was gonna look i
needed to pick up some shoes or i
thought i'd seen this cute pair of shoes
i thought i'd go and look at them again
you know and i thought i'd look at those
dresses right i'd do some clothes
shopping before i met x
right and and then so then they would
might be flipping in and out so they
might be looking at the map of cambridge
so they might see themselves kind of
traversing
in a cambridge you know having cycled
you know so gps tells you your mode of
transport as well implicitly so so
that's the way they use it yeah i'm
trying to understand this graph because
if i read it the way it looks it says
that given just memory people remember
only one event every three days no no no
thank you so mean number of events
recalled must be something other than
what it says
this is average across so that's correct
your interpretation is absolutely
correct so most of the time when we say
to people you know if i was to say to
you hey terry what did you do you know
and i don't put you on the spot but what
do you know what were you doing on
you know uh
february the 26th
assuming that's not your birthday or you
know your wife's birthday yeah in the
morning you say i don't know
if you tell me it's a tuesday then i can
give you some
yeah okay we'll come back to that in a
second because that's positive yeah so
anybody else
building on that i'm wondering
so even in the best case people
are remembering
one and three quarters
events on average
yeah so that's a half day yes that's the
hell update sorry okay yeah so this is
the half day result so that's why i've
multiplied it by so basically this is
saying on a day i i get two two-thirds
of it you know so i get two events every
three days
just for my own
right
yes okay so let's say it's three and a
half events i should obviously re-scale
this graph yeah it's closing the one
computer yeah
question was actually
i'm curious what the
ground truth is
so so so i guess we have not followed
people around but i think your calendar
is not a bad proxy for
you know what the best and it may not be
you know that may be an undershoot for
what your number of events actually is
like is this a third of what we do is
this 90 oh i see what's it
so i i think this is not good
um i think it's
yeah well it's certainly compared with
the lifelong vision you know so our
we're expecting like 15 extra right and
we're we're just surprised not to see
that yeah
that's right your information might just
be we're boring
so this is a question
so i went through my day and long yes
what is the baseline number you would
get from that yeah so i think that's a
good question and i'm saying that we
have not done that but i think the
calendar is not a bad proxy which would
basically you know so you think right my
calendar usually i've got probably about
six or seven calendar events and then
i've got family stuff around it
right
see you know that's maybe not bad yeah
and so how much of this is i just have i
can't tell which day i should be good
okay okay
so
we ask people after they've done all
that right so this is kind of important
to understand because it tells us
something about memory as well okay so
we asked people about that we're saying
you know i wouldn't say you're
absolutely crap but we said you know you
seem not to be you know so what's what's
going on here and then the first point
is your point which is like there's so
many images
right how do i deal with all this stuff
right and then this other point which is
just everybody you know so
i i always
anything i do i always do myself first
right and i was kind of a bit down when
i saw how much in my life i'm in front
of a bloody computer
right but i don't know which
you know so if you were to
which day is that
i don't know that's a meeting i'm
meeting like say meeting michael you
know if that's a if that's a one-on-one
weekly
i don't know which one it is right so so
part of the problem here is and that's
kind of a classic attribute of
human memory is it moves from being very
very highly specific so you have these
one-off events which is kind of the way
that we tend to think about how memory
is but a lot of it's kind of boring
stuff and the way that human memory
works is it kind of evolves a script
across it abstracts out and you know if
that's a one-on-one they all lied into
each other right one faculty meeting
one class is you know the first class is
exciting but then they begin to allied
it's an instance of a type and you don't
have a lot of instantiations of of
different details and that's the problem
that people running into with it
okay so you know then we looked at other
so this is attribute so once you're
talking about an event
then um
you know one question we can ask is what
kind of which of the interfaces help you
get kind of more details
and the snaps you know for fairly
obvious reasons they help you get more
details about an event so people say
things like i found the sensor cam
pictures really useful for those micro
events that happen those days so once
you've got the event you can kind of
read out from it yeah
actually hide some of the photos why
would people do worse good right we
always design an interface right because
we had to key off you had to key off
location to get to image and i think
that each we should just have had those
kind of be simultaneous
right so that's i think that's a
piece of misdesign but well spotted yeah
okay and then this other question i
talked about earlier which is this recon
so we basically say to people you know
remember this thing is like
did you see it in your mind's eye or
were you kind of guessing it
right and so what we see yeah sorry
reconstructing it so you look at that
thing you say what must have been
happening right and so what you see is
with these location-based technologies
people are doing more of this kind of
inferencing so they're saying where was
i oh i'm going to kind of work out what
i was doing right
um you know so this is this interesting
cool one which is about kind of speed of
travel snaps made me
made me remember snap tracks and tracks
those location based maybe figure out
something which must have happened in a
particular way for example i must have
gone home by taxi right so this person
they're used to seeing those pins spaced
in a particular way because they walk or
take a bike right suddenly they see
themselves doing these traversals
of distance very quickly so they make an
inference right and they've got an image
of themselves inside a car so they they
sort of see that
okay
and then
we we also and this is completely
consistent with the psychological
literature
which says that um if you can see
something in your mind's eye not all
memories are actually visual but a lot
of autobiographical ones are there's
emotion associated with them um
organic memory that's the you know
uh that's wet wear was useless i could
have no emotional attachment to those
memories but the tools especially snaps
i guess meaning images across both
conditions were very good at reviewing
accurate memories so people kind of feel
more positive about these things
okay so
um
this is kind of i'm gonna terminate the
first part of the talk um
so
what i'm trying to argue here is that a
rich record doesn't necessarily
guarantee total recall and part of the
problem is that a lot of these images
can be confusable
and that might relate to kind of the
habitual nature of our lives
that these memories are often
reconstructive so that's say you're
using
the digital as a set of cues to
reconstruct and these pictures are very
evocative right now i don't really want
to go into a
big technical digression because i kind
of want to move on to the next
conceptual point but one of the
questions which i guess you over there i
don't know your name i'm sorry we're
talking about how can we process these
um in particular one of the big problems
is over generation right so we have i
want to talk really quickly about two
ideas one idea is co-ended co-indexing
by attention or user action so here's a
simple example uh michael would be
totally familiar with this because it's
like the one eye technical idea i've
ever had which is like if somebody takes
a note or somebody takes a picture we
can infer actively that they're
interested in something
so what if we could co-index those
actions onto
you know that stream of pictures then we
could infer that those things were kind
of more important
so that's one way
so that's kind of co-indexing say off
sensors
and then
the other way which we actually built a
couple of systems to do was if somebody
repeatedly accesses the same image we're
going to infer it's important
right
just because they've looked at it
multiple times so
um
one of the systems we built um
basically use this idea and we use it in
two sensors
we can make we can do so basically
frequently retrieved and popular
pictures
we use those as cues to import and
you're michael totally familiar with
this right this kind of crowd sourcing
so it's like individual crowd so if i
multiply if i access an image multiple
times i'm going to infer that's more
important and in our ui it grows
right so this is like manga style it
grows the more you access it the bigger
it looks and the more salient it's
supposed to be right but also we can
crowdsource that and we built a kind of
lecture deployment which is seeing here
which is across a class
right you can if i see
if if multiple people access the same
image across a class like this if we if
we had this type of technology deployed
in this type of class then
these
more popular images would be seen as
kind of more important in that context
so those are two ways to kind of get
ourselves out of this trap of over
generation it's to try and use people's
actions as indicators or proxies for
importance
okay
so
so i now want to kind of revisit
this idea about kind of fixing memory
right so the life logging vision it
basically says
memory is broken here comes technology
to the rescue
well what if we tried to take a slightly
different perspective right so instead
of trying to fix organic memory by
recording everything what if we try to
emulate in some ways okay so let's just
i'll give you a quick tiny tour of how
human autobiographical memory works in
practice
so these are some of the arguments one
argument is that forgetting is adaptive
right so simple example when you go out
to the car park looking for your car you
don't want to remember every single
instance of when you ever parked that
car
be kind of nice if you forgot all the
previous ones right so that's a simple
example
so one that's one argument about
adaptivity of forgetting
um there's also um something called
positivity bias which says and and i'll
show you the uh the data on this in a
second that one of the things that we as
people do is we forget negative or
upsetting things
okay so
you know quick kind of uh whiz through
uh memory and emotion right so there's a
lot of so you can ask people about their
paths using a variety of different
methods you can ask them to journal you
can ask them to talk about big salient
events from their past whatever you want
to do
there's a repeated result which is
people remember twice as many positive
as negative events right and i guess
neutral comes in about 30
so that's one thing that people do right
the second thing
really interesting result is this thing
called the fading affect bias right and
i've tried to depict it here
what so if something happens to us and
we think about it again generally the
affect that we have that's associated
with that drops so here's a highly
positive event right the ones in yellow
we rethink it it drops over time so you
know you just won the lottery you think
about it again you're not going to be as
positive as that first moment when that
thing happened right
that's the fading affect bit now the
bias bit here are negative events right
negative events fade much more quickly
right faster regression to the mean than
positive events so what's that what does
this mean
it means that if something really bad
happens to you then you kind of get over
it more quickly than if something really
good happens to you and you that starts
slowly attenuating
right so emotional general emotional
strength drops the negative drops faster
right i'm going to talk about that a bit
more with our system later the other
thing which is kind of cute is this
thing called the rosy view
which is that we tend to kind of edit
out the negative right so there's these
really cool studies where they do things
like they ask people about vacations
right
uh you know both at the time and
afterwards so they would have people
logging a vacation and they'd have them
you know on the plane right and so what
people's accounts say on the place let's
say we're going to disneyland right
on the plane and people are saying
things like there's this really fat
person next to me god their elbows are
really poking into me right at the time
so you say what's your affect like right
now and they say it's it's about a five
on a scale of one to ten right i'm
looking forward to being there but this
is a painless flight right you ask him
about that
part of the trip afterwards it's a seven
right so we edit out you know so you ask
disney you know disney world or whatever
right
you look at their logs they're not you
know at the time they're talking about
oh my god look at these lines right i
can't believe that you know
you know
you know a thousand people are waiting
for pirates the caribbean right and then
you ask them about you know how they
felt a month or two later fantastic
right so that's one thing that's so this
is
another way that we're basically
self-editing so we
edit out you know the negative or
annoying details
okay so now what we want to do is we
want to take these kind of ideas into a
context into the digital context because
it starts to get a little bit different
in the digital context because what we
have in the digital context is kind of
like it's veritable right so if you go
onto facebook and you say god x is
really pissing me off
right
you know and you look at that three
weeks later it's not
suddenly got to being
gosh what a good friend x is
right which is what human memory might
say because it's right there right so
you've kind of logged it
okay so this is so we're interested in
exploring this because this this is a
situation where we may not want perfect
recall
okay so
very quickly on breakup and memory so
the things that we tend to remember are
aligned with our self-concept right
those are the things we remember best
one of the problems with breakup is you
know your relationship is kind of very
much part of your identity what people
tend to do in a relationship breakup
situation is they kind of redefine
themselves and then there's a problem
because their new self isn't triggering
the right set of memories
so
um as a british person i love this idea
there's this mechanism which is called
selective repression you know as a
british person we never want to talk
about negative stuff we never we just
never bring it up right so that's the
mechanism that's been argued is helpful
in this context
okay so we did
so the idea behind this study is to try
and understand this a situation where
people make quotes want to forget and
then what we want to do is we want to
think about designs that might follow
from understanding that situation well
so we have 24 digital natives you know
so these are people who are kind of
living online
um and they had to experience a recent
breakup following a long-term
relationship
okay so here are some of the problems
with digital records which you know you
guys will be just totally familiar with
right
so there's a bunch of stuff that we have
you know on our personal systems which
is like super evocative right so we've
all got personal mute you know whether
this is on you know when i say personal
i mean it could be on the cloud as part
of our account right but music's very
evocative we've got our personal photos
and obviously stuff we do on the social
networking site it's all kind of uh it
engenders emotions
the other characteristic of it is it's
kind of ubiquitous that's to say we're
always kind of encountering it
right so it's you know it's part of our
stuff you know you go into facebook you
see this you go into file system you go
into your email you're constantly being
reminded of significant people in your
life right the other thing is most
people's stuff is not particularly well
organized so it's kind of hard to
compartmentalize stuff if you actually
wanted to do that
the other thing final thing is kind of
highly available right so people we
found out have very different
strategies on this right so you can
unfriend
right but if you choose not to unfriend
then it's very very easy these days to
find out exactly what your ex is doing
just with one click right and we did
have people in the study who would
unfriend people and then they would go
to their
friend's house
log into their friend you know their
friend they say i need to look at your
facebook account because you're still
friends with my ex and then they look
right so the problem is this information
is just so much more accessible
okay so you know life's now online in a
serious way so in this situation we're
often one click away from highly
upsetting information so you know people
say i miss him his uploads on facebook
make me feel hurt what hurts her
pictures with his new friends and
experiences because i can see him but i
can't talk to him right and we know
there's a bunch of stuff on facebook in
and relationships which says it's very
facebook's very misleading because
there's no context for posts
right stuff goes up and you don't know
the context so there's a lot of
misinterpretation
then this point i already made that it's
very easy because our personal stuff is
a mess it's very easy to accidentally
encounter highly upsetting information
there are some songs that recall
feelings from that period i listen to
them and this hinders moving on pitches
always make me remember a good memory so
i try not to look at them at all because
good memories also linked to a bad
memory
okay so that was then we started looking
at what people did with this stuff right
and we found you know crudely
that there were three ways that people
dealt with this situation so something
you know and you can maybe think about
people's real life strategies to
relationships so we got three types you
know one some people like it's over they
try and trash everything immediately
then there are some other people who
keep everything
right and we'll talk about how they deal
with it and then we've got people who
are kind of more uh i guess strategic
about when and what they delete so i'm
just going to talk through those people
right
you know so some people they just say
it's over right having photos on my
phone and computer did cause me to feel
sad but i immediately removed them all
after the breakup in order to move on
right
of course the problems with this
you know because
you know if you immediately delete
everything about a relationship you're
kind of
you at the time you might feel it's it's
an it's like a negative event but if you
when you think back when you kind of got
through it you can't kind of write off
three years of your life you can't say
there was nothing valuable there so when
people feel better about it they want to
salvage something but then they've
trashed everything so people say some
books and music will continue to remind
me of him i can keep those because i
felt it would not be productive for my
attempts to move on now i wish i kept
them
okay so here's the other type right
i kept everything right and this can be
quite disruptive pictures hindered my
moving on
when i look to them uh at them it would
make me remember him i just try not to
look at them but at the very beginning
of the breakup i looked at them
frequently those possessions didn't help
me right so this is the kind of
immediate accessibility problem
okay and then we've got the
i love this i just love this right
so so so then we've got some people who
are kind of thinking about it right
so then they do this kind of
you know technical stuff where they
might create a hidden folder they might
kind of and and this is a problem you
know for you know if i want to find all
the stuff about x and put it in one
location
that's a tricky
thing to do right
so i deleted all the message that back
them up i put all the digital material
into a file i set it as hidden right
people might hide stuff on their old
phone and then this is getting to
getting to be super interesting right so
they appoint gatekeepers so they might
give them the memories they might give
them the us usb or the old laptop or
whatever and say
don't let me have that right kind of
interest so we'll come to the designs in
a minute but that's kind of starting to
get really interesting okay so then um
the the selective people are doing
something in between i actually had a
little cleanup there deleted a bunch of
emails i had from her cleared all her
stuff off my computer and deleted my
number from her phone but it kept the
photos someday i might want to revisit
some of the times we share just not
right now yeah
disposable strategy would would be to
have a time limit right so yes
yeah that's yeah so right exactly that's
that yeah that's great okay so it just
wanted we have not built these systems
but actually anybody here no kill switch
it's a kill switch is like a startup
that says they it's for the deleters
right so you see
and the idea is you know i'm not sure
technically how it does it because i
think it's technically it's a really
difficult problem to say
find me all information about x
right and then harvest it in a
particular place and trash it right so i
could see within the scope of particular
applications you could do that but
anyway this is the way this product yeah
is this on my laptop or if like you and
i are together and then you break up
with me i can kill switch like you're no
you can't guess what
or your own accounts which and it's it's
a product i i just i mean it's being
sold but it's the usual i don't know
whether it does because i can't
technically work out how it could do
what it's kind of projected to do right
i mean certainly not completely
right so you could see if you've
labeled all your photos in the right
kind of way and you know being very good
about tagging then it would have a
chance but you know i just don't see it
somehow anyway but that's so one idea
which
you know which
is i guess you could partially get there
is to start thinking about technologies
like entity recognition
you know so could you kind of extract
references to that person you know and
names you know and collect all that
stuff together
um i guess the the technologies i found
more interesting the designs i found
more interesting in this context were
along the lines that you were suggesting
which is once you've kind of got a lot
of that stuff together which as i say is
kind of a difficult technical problem in
in and of itself
there are things that you might want to
do to kind of stop you immediately
accessing it right because one of the
things that one person talked to us
about was like the drunken phone call
right and this you know so it's like you
have the contact number you know you're
in a poor state emotionally you can't
stop yourself right so what these uh
types of designs might do is if all that
material is
in a location that's kind of you have a
timeout right so you could set some
parameter which says you know i'm not
you know i may express a desire to do
this but i can't execute on it for 24
hours right till i'm sober for example
right so that might be or you know you
could have the gatekeeper which is that
person owns it and we have to have a
chat we have to have a chat before you
know it has to be an exchange of info
before they'll kind of give me
you know the key and i can get in the
other one was physical distance which is
that you could which some people did
which is they took that laptop and they
gave it put it in a physically different
location so all those things might cause
you know might help you
do the impulse control by making it
really difficult to kind of follow
through on this kind of self-destructive
urge
and then there's these other things
which we didn't really see
i mean i guess those um
kind of uh selective disposers so a lot
of the uh i guess the relationship
literature talks about the need to kind
of extract and process
aspects of that um you know set of
possessions you had together um so we
you know we're interested in
technologies that would actually allow
you for example to
you know make some kind of album or
something you know but to creatively
process that because that's meant to be
very healing
okay so those those are not built um
you know but they are design ideas that
we're really interested in exploring
okay so um anybody any questions about
that
by the way this went viral
on the internet i had so many you know
like people i guess
people want to know facebook's really
bad for us so yeah another interesting
design
to link it to another project like you
know if you can keep that closed or
locked that file i mean locked for a
couple of time and you can't like link
it to lose your weight something like
that but
yeah that reminds me right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you exactly
have a project like if you can every day
you can keep your phone like on the
table for 10 minutes then unicef will
donate
i think one dollar or something too yeah
yeah that's great yeah yeah yeah so you
could
get that sort of i i guess and there's a
reverse you know
if you can you know if you don't stay
off that i give 50 to the republican
party that you know there's
you can have them but work both ways
right
okay and and then this this was this was
an idea that some of so this is in the
spirit of kind of actively physically
processing uh this stuff
okay and then the last thing um which i
guess facebook weren't very responsive
to was you know it's at the moment um
you know what facebook is is it's kind
of weird i mean it's it's a friend's
site but it's not a good site for
managing your relationships through
because there's no notion of kind of
tying your stuff together to another
person's right so people talk about a
lot of problems where their
really
private personal stuff was under
somebody else's control and they did so
we had ideas that you might actually
have like um you know there'd be a
special area of facebook which was about
you know close relationships which
for
relationships which were moving
positively could be used for celebration
right and then if things did go wrong
then you could have something that was
closer to the kind of kill switch
facility but basically you wouldn't have
this problem of kind of managing your
relationship through all these different
kind of proxy
type links complex proxy type links
anyway i did not get much traction in in
conversations with with facebook about
that
okay so um
so so this is a different approach um i
talked about the value of adaptive
forgetting um distinct strategies for
disposal of digital possessions and some
design implications uh for doing digital
disposal
okay
so the last thing i want to talk about
today is some recent work we've been
doing on i guess reflection
which is kind of trying to think deeply
about digital records and how this
relates to
to well-being excuse me
so um
we're
we're trying to and and
so i guess there's a this whole
quantified self movement which is like
have data about yourself understand
yourself right so we're in this area but
what we want to do is we want to provide
ways to use these types of personal
records to kind of better understand
ourselves so let me talk about and we're
interested in the emotions realm
right so
one of the problems that we have as
people is this problem that we call
emotion pattern detection right
so you know so let me show you this
example this is from one of our users
who used our system for about a year and
this is like this is her days of the
week right
so what this shows you is that she's
pretty happy on a monday
she's terrible on her
i guess this mo no no no no sunday
this is thursday right so she gets
sadder during the week and but you won't
be too surprised about that but she
didn't know it right so that's an
example
of an emotional pattern which
these types of systems are actually
going to yield up to us and i'll show
you a few more of these kind of things
later so what we can do so as i say in
our lives the connection between
things that happen to us things we do
and our emotional reactions are quite
complex
if we can kind of record and kind of
externalize and visualize those
connections we can better understand
ourselves and we can kind of proceed
adaptively so if we like things we can
seek them out
if
if we don't like things you know we can
seek to avoid them
and i'm going to talk what we found
really interesting about the deployment
of this system is that people actually
using it for kind of behavior change
which is they were using it to monitor
things they were doing that made them
kind of unhappy
and using the system to actually change
those behaviors
okay
so
what i've shifted to now talking about
is not just remembering stuff but recon
stroll and i want to really quickly talk
about some i think fascinating uh
research on emotional writing which is
as
talking about and reprocessing our past
so i guess you know this right this
isn't this just fascinating okay so
what penny baker does is he has people
journal
say you're really upset about something
right
what he has people do is repeatedly
write about that event right and this is
the kind of thing that happens right
there's now over 200 studies with this
kind of reflection on your
negative past so what the effect the
effects you get are reduced medical
visits improved immune response better
grades re-employment reduced absenteeism
increased subjective well-being
increased working memory
right and the argument behind this is
that
what this type of exercise allows people
to do is to distance themselves from
negative events but also to see
themselves as a kind of hero in their
own narrative in which they've kind of
they've uh accomplished they've got past
some very negative past event so they
say
you know some terrible stuff has
happened to me but i feel good about
that event now because that's what
happens if you repeatedly write about it
and so i feel good about it now
therefore i'm some person who can cope
with past negative events now i told you
about 10 minutes ago that one of the
things our memories do is edit out
negative events so they're not doing
anything fantastic beyond it but this is
how people feel they take a positive
message from this situation which is i'm
feeling much better about it now
therefore i'm resilient
okay and also you can get the same kind
of benefits but a bit reduced so if you
if you think about positive things that
have happened to you so this is like the
you know
sharing photos uh you know experience
you know you look at family photos you
share stuff on facebook you know
generally if it's a social event you
feel better and there's a bunch of
literature not as strong events as as
with the negative past but still um good
effects okay so we wanted to explore
these ideas with a system because we
think penny baker this type of thing can
be done much better with the system
right because if you've got a mobile app
that you can kind of log events on and
rewrite about so you can log them at the
time that's really how you felt right
also we can have the system
actively present those back to you so in
the penny baker style you have to kind
of get your paper log out you have to
make sure you find a time in the day to
kind of go back and you know write about
that past negative event what our system
does is it presents them back to you
both positive and negative and ask you
about how you're thinking about them now
so it's pretty easy for you to log
things that are happening to you i guess
more veritably because you log them you
know there's i guess now there's no
there's no you know people are using
their phones all the time right so it's
not like what's that person doing they
could be texting right the fact they
happen to be logging their life is
yeah you have any information on how
much logging is natural to people
because you ask them to log a lot of
information
but at what point did that become
lawrence or
i think
we have about um
16 of people are quite happy to do this
and i would say are kind of active
journalists right
so we don't have to pay them anything a
lot of the study i'm we give people like
a you know 20 depending on their
20 to 50
dollar uh incentive to so it's a lot of
work but we wanted to make sure
that we could see the effects of it
right so i think i think the whole
question about um you know what
compliance with all these all health
applications is a big one this one i'd
say about 16 of people who do it
naturally what's really interesting to
me is there's a kind of paradox
because
i can
at our exit interviews people are saying
tell me how great this system is i say
do you want to keep it they say yes and
then i you know i get back in touch four
months later
you know i've seen i can make them
happier objectively they think they're
happier they stop using it
right but that's human you know we all
know there's a bunch of things we can do
to
you know be better people and healthier
people but we don't do them right
okay so um this is what you basically do
is um and i i'll put the we these are
both
free downloadable android iphone right
i'll finish with those links i'd love if
you want to use them fantastic okay
you journal any daily event you
emotionally rate it we just play it back
to you you know like um so this is um
you know one of our long term users one
event from three oh you take photo
evocative two event from three years ago
so she can now reflect on that one
two years ago one year ago one month ago
right so you're just logging as many
most people most of our long-term use
they're doing like two or three a day
and then you know forever however long
we've got some not very clever algorithm
which presents stuff back to you which
is normally like a month later
a year later because there is there is
something to kind of calendar
cycladicity okay so let me just
uh so this that you create an entry this
way take a photo i want to get to the
data and i'm a bit concerned about time
here so let me just whiz through so um
what we did was a kind of a classic
intervention study
we measure people's well-being you know
using standard scales then we have um
three different conditions
uh record and reflect is our echo system
recorders we just have them record
events that's you don't see them back
um and then we have a bunch of controls
which were an absolute pig to run but i
don't really want to get into so um you
know recorders uh you know they that's
what they're doing reflectors
they get they see the events multiple
times everybody understand that
difference okay
um
so
these are the well-being scores and um
all of these groups surprisingly to us
both recorders and reflectors
they improve their subjective well-being
and our the controls are flat i can
share that data
in a sec if you're interested
and then we did um we did textual
analyses of the logs which they shared
with us so everybody gets a chance to
edit their logs and share or not share
because this is private stuff and then
we do textual analysis because we want
to see
what were the kind of ways that people
were talking about their emotions that
would that were kind of correlated with
improvements of well-being and what we
saw was that people are just recording
they're using the system very
differently from the people are
reflecting
um you know so people are recording
they're talking about relationships
reflectors are talking about actions and
they're uh they're often future directed
so i'll give you a couple of examples of
that
you know so recorders analyze their life
especially their relationships the
reflectors reported on their activities
but later drew lessons when they had
perspective both from positive and
negative events
so um
i'm not gonna dwell on that this is yeah
this is one person just reflecting on
her attitudes to
men and you know i guess these uh
eternal gender issues
okay so um so this is how you can kind
of use the uh the study to kind of
reflect on uh emotional habits i'm kind
of getting worried about my assignment
because there's some questions items on
there that i don't know how to do or
answer i'm afraid i won't get full
credit so she's got a sick she's not
amazingly happy about it right you know
i'm starting to realize that so long as
we do a decent job on the assignments we
get full credit so i don't feel like i
should stress so much so she's thinking
about that past event although her score
hasn't increased she's getting happier
about it or i mean in her text she's
getting happier here's another one
this person's really unhappy i should
say that one is the unhappiest you could
be my boyfriend's not texting me often
enough
frowny i really wish he would text me
more often
right and then i'm sorry you can't read
this probably i guess i'm not that angry
i i'm sure i can at times be that crazy
girlfriend who texts too much and is
overbearing so i'm sure he can get
annoyed too right so um i guess i elided
this but she's gone up to about a five
here so she's thought about her behave
past behavior and kind of got happier
about it so this is the way that they're
using the system a lot of the time
okay so i'm not going to have time i
just want to make sure so this is
learning from positive so one question
that we had you know was we're actually
messing with memory here so the point i
i made at the outset was you know what
people are now seeing is actually how
they felt warts and all about past
events
but you know so what the technology is
showing us is what we actually thought
at the time but nevertheless we're still
getting these positive effects so even
though you can see literally how you
felt at the time right so this is not
edited memory like we usually get but
you still get these well-being effects
so i just wanted to really quickly
finish up with this long-term stuff
which me is really interesting so we
show people visualizations so we show
people like days of the week
and then we ask them you know did you
know that you had this cycle throughout
the days of the week
we can show them like moving window
through their emotions right so this
person's kind of getting happier
throughout the study she got a new job
here right so we say to people you know
well what can you tell from that kind of
visualization so she told that you know
people are interested in maxima and
minima in these situations right so what
led to that increase they want to think
about these types of events and
obviously having these types of records
gives them insight into things that were
happening in their lives
this one is not the greatest
visualization i'm not a visualization
person as you probably knew right but
this shows the redemption narrative so
what we do here is we take
all the negative events and we show
their gradient right and so what a
uh you know i guess a positive gradient
shows is that you started sad about
something and you got happier and what
you'll see is there's only one exception
in this person's data where something
started happier and got sadder right so
you can show them that kind of thing and
and they you know you explain it to them
and then they start drawing these
inferences about their own resilience
right which is bad things happen i tend
to feel happier about them subsequently
okay so just want to finish it you know
so what people say about the system at
the exit interviews it gives you a
window onto what you're feeling it gives
insight in order to change
both from a positive perspective if
something makes me happy i'll do it
again
negative echo gave me a snap a snapshot
of meltdown moments i could look at
those and see that those things weren't
normal it forced me to confront my
reactions and myself i learned from it
when i saw one of those memories i saw
that i needed therapy and this is true
this person actually went and sought
professional help as a result of using
our system recording it putting it down
thinking that that's not the way i want
to be
okay so i'm just going to skip through
we've got a lot more
i just want to finish up just leave a
bit of time
so
life logging doesn't totally fix
fallible memory that's what i try to
show you at the outset
there are arguments that we can learn
from these ideas that memories adaptive
get some interesting designs looking at
context where people want to forget and
then what i want to argue is that i
think there's some real opportunities
with well-being and mental health to be
using these kind of really lightweight
logging type applications um to kind of
understand ourselves and our past a
little better and i think it's good in
this context you know as a as an
antidote to nsa where everybody's afraid
of you know like masses of data to say
you know there are contexts in which
where we have own and appropriate this
data we can use it to help ourselves
okay thank you very much
okay so so those are i just want to
thank those people who have collaborated
on various of these
projects and then as i say
the echo stuff now you can download it
free and if you like it or you hate it
let us know
you